confidential computing protects your
data in use through hardware-based
trusted execution environments
otherwise called enclaves but how do you
adopt the secure enclaves to truly
protect your applications end-to-end
how does this align with your container
or community strategy
and do you need new skills or additional
devops workflows to adopt them
today we are going to talk about
confidential computing
and specifically how easy it is to adopt
tes or trusted execution environments
and to protect your cloud workloads
using ibm cloud data shield
at a high level confidential computing
protects data through
encryption and isolation of memory which
complements your data in transit
encryption using tls
and at rest encryption which is envelope
encryption using a root key
for a true end-to-end protection and
this cryptographic isolation of memory
happens either at a vm level or the
process level
you can think of it as a vm level
cryptographic isolation
or process level cryptographic isolation
for today let's focus on process level
cryptographic solutions or secure
enclaves
let's look at intel software guard
extensions and how datashield can help
you adopt intel sgx
with no code changes intel software
guard extensions is a set of security
related instruction
codes that are built into some of the
modern intel cpus
they allow user level as well as
operating system code to define
private regions of memory again enclaves
whose contents are protected and unable
to be either
read or saved by any process outside the
enclave itself
including processes running at higher
privilege levels
so where do you begin first you start
with kubernetes cluster
you can provision either an ibm
kubernetes service or red hat open shift
on ibm cloud cluster
with intel hdx capable worker nodes next
you install data shield helm chart on
your cluster
this installs your own dedicated single
tenant data shield instance
on your cluster which includes an ui and
an api
the api seamlessly aligns with your
cloud native strategy
and integrates with your devops
pipelines to convert your container
images
to intel sgx capable secure enclave
counterparts
using industry's best runtime encryption
technology from photonics
datashield pulls your container image
from your registry converts and pushes
the new image back to your registry
without you having to make any code
changes you can now update your
kubernetes deployment yaml
and deploy your new runtime memory
encrypted application to your cluster
and yes datashield also takes the
complexity away from attestation
and presents you the attestation report
through a public key infrastructure
that runs native to your cluster this
gives you the additional layer of
technical assurance that you
need and the ui helps with user access
management
presents you with the attestation
reports gives you privileges to allow
or deny a certain enclave and even has
an intuitive tool to convert your
application for a quick demo
or a proof of concept so to recap
datashield is a single tenant software
that runs on your kubernetes cluster
and helps you adopt intel hdx secure
enclaves
with technical assurances through
attestation reports and with
no code changes